hey everyone i'm jesse i'm a registered
nurse and entrepreneur and i make weekly
videos on minimalism and healthy living
to help you live a simpler happier life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm so excited about this video because
i just changed jobs
so i thought it'd be helpful to share
some tips with you to help you in your
transition
tip number one is do not bad mouth your
previous employer
no matter how much you want to my
favorite behavioral investigator vanessa
van edwards
says that when you speak negatively
about others
other people are much more likely to
attribute those characteristics that
you're speaking about
right back to you and not only is it
just not wise to be the spreader of
gossip
but what if you end up wanting a
partnership a job reference
or you actually end up wanting that job
back you might have just closed those
doors on yourself
number two kind of goes along with the
whole closing doors thing is
keep in touch with positive
relationships from your previous job
i kind of used to think about this
differently when i was younger because i
saw it as an opportunity to start over
where nobody really knows you yet and
you have new relationships
but i've come to realize that having
strong positive relationships can
really be a key to success because the
truth is we don't know everything
and we are not the strongest in
everything believing that we don't need
anybody else's help or guidance is an
easy way to destroy ourselves so by
building these relationships from
different areas you're creating a
network of individuals
that can help guide you and help you
along your path to success
and who you can be of service to as well
and by keeping in touch with these
individuals
it does not mean contact them once a
year and then hope that they'll give you
a reference when you start this
xyz project make it a conscious effort
to keep in touch
and take interest in their personal
lives before we go to number three
i want to know how good are you with
keeping in touch with others
let me know in the comments tip number
three
might be an odd one but it is given
notice
when appropriate i say this because not
all jobs are created equal my brother's
friend worked in a mechanic shop and he
tried to do the right thing
by giving a notice the day that he did
he was told to leave on the spot
another friend of mine was thinking
about leaving her current position
so she warned her boss about it her boss
actually ended up hiring her replacement
before she even got the job she was
hoping for
long story short this did not work out
well for her she ended up with cut hours
and a strong financial burden now i am
not
saying that you should not place a
notice but
don't announce it to the world before
it's actually set in stone
number four don't be afraid to be honest
about the reason that you're leaving
but don't do it with resentment a friend
of mine was leaving her position because
she felt like she wasn't advancing in
the company
when she voiced this she was actually
offered a promotion
you don't have to hide the reasons that
you're leaving but be tactful about it
number five when you actually do change
jobs find a person that can be your
mentor and serve as a guide
this can be a person that's training you
or somebody that you feel comfortable
with
asking for feedback this can be almost
like having an accountability partner
where you can have somebody that you
feel okay with being
open and knowing what you're doing wrong
and what you can do better
number six i think is very important
it's to develop a positive relationship
with your boss
yes it is important to have a good first
impression with your co-workers
but especially your boss because after
all this is the person who has the final
say in your promotion
or those vacation days you need last
minute so something to try is be
friendly and just take interest in
other people's lives and not just
talking about yourself
number seven i've got to say is probably
the most important to me of all is
don't stop growing if this job is not
your dream job
don't knock yourself down because you
haven't gotten to your final goal yet
if for example your goal is to be an
entrepreneur think of this as an
opportunity to get to where you want to
be
it's just a step in the process
so if for example you do want to be your
own boss someday
think of this as a learning opportunity
this is practice
you're learning what you like in an
employer what you don't like about their
communication skills
what you don't or do like about the way
that they run their company
before this is actually your
responsibility
and you're the one who's responsible for
the outcomes
so focus on the progress you're making
and the things that you're actually
progressing in
because as i mentioned in my previous
video how to accomplish big projects
you're either progressing in life or
regressing but there's no in the middle
so what will you choose that's all for
today i'm so thankful that you stuck
around till the end
if you like this video please give me a
like and subscribe so you won't miss out
on my weekly videos
bye for now don't stop
[Music]
growing